investigations of former president
donald trump and his company
are entering a serious new phase now cbs
news has learned that one of those
probes is bringing evidence to a new
grand jury which could potentially lead
to criminal charges
now the former president calls the
investigation purely political
driven by highly partisan democrat
prosecutors
cbs news legal analyst ricky kleeman
joins us to discuss
good morning to you ricky so how big a
deal is this latest
how big a deal is this latest
development and should donald trump be
worried he doesn't sound like he is
yes it is a big deal and yes donald
trump should be very worried
psy vance the district attorney has
investigated this case
with a team of prosecutors investigators
forensic
accountants for two years for him to go
to the next step
of impaneling a special grand jury
is really means that they are looking at
a possible prosecution
the question is of who or what the trump
organization
donald trump himself his children or
alan weisselberg
we need to talk a little about allen
weisselberg he holds the keys to the
kingdom
he is the chief financial officer the
treasurer
there is no transaction financially that
did not go
through alan weisselberg how did this
all begin
michael cohen testified in congress and
he said
that values of properties were inflated
in order to get loans
deflated in order to pay taxes
so what would the d.a be looking at
possible charges of bank fraud
insurance fraud tax fraud this
is a problem for donald trump if allen
weisselberg
becomes a witness against him so what is
his defense at this point
his defense ultimately is i did what i
was told
my accountants looked at it my banks
looked
at it my financial people looked at it
and i signed the documents and others
signed the documents
i never had any intent to break any law
that's always the defense scale in cases
like this
all right ricky clement thank you good
to see you